foreign
okay
first of all and the
phone call that i received was from
someone saying we're not
we're not being broadcast so
so
maybe that was good
but they're having they're down
on
house
bill
renaming the department of environmental
services
well we do i'm not going to read the
whole title
uh
having voted on the prevailing side i'm
i move reconsideration
we have a side here a second
second by representative huff
uh
on reconsideration
will the clerk please call the role
yes
we have to vote
representative smith for a motion
i make a motion to interim study house
bill 1452
yes
we're recons this we're reconsidering it
and this is now some we've reconsidered
it it is now uh
on the floor
for another vote
uh
motion is uh
is
uh
second the motion uh
do you wish do you wish to speak on your
motion no
i think i said it all earlier and i
stand by what i said thanks
representative vail as do i thank you mr
chair
else wish to speak on the on the motion
seeing none will the clerk please call
the role
yes
cohen yes
consent seeing none seeing no objection
people will be on consent
like i said
this has been a
day all right house going uh to how back
to house bill
1005.
uh where did we we stand the motion uh
was the motion was made uh was
made and seconded on uh
house
on the amendment you have a new
amendment
uh
so the
why don't why don't we maybe we're just
better off starting over
is that all right
thank you mr chair um well let me first
we gotta withdraw the motion on the uh
what is what was the original uh
amendment
i'm not gonna start over we'll just uh
which we have to draw the origin the
motion on the original amendment
all right
what you just handed out is that
unfortunately
all right
okay and uh
okay
making the motion
all right the withdrawal we're drawing
uh
four four four
okay i'll make it um i would like to
make a motion to withdraw the amendment
of zero four three one h
i guess okay
who made the second on that
uh
well
oh you made the motion i'll make well
i'll i'll second it
is there uh
yeah what i was looking i don't know who
had the second
anybody remember whom did the second all
right yes
who yeah representative huffman i read
the second he withdraw he withdraws
okay motion withdrawn all right on the
on then for
amendment 445h
yes chair recognizes representative
harvey bullio to
uh for the to
uh deduce the amendment it's a great to
adopt the amendment
uh thank you chair i wish to make a
motion of ought to pass on house bill
1005 in support of our low-grade timber
um
markets since we are the second um most
forested state in the nation
amendment what
you know this is not on the uh the
motion this is just to adopt the motion
amendment excuse me okay
i am yes make a motion
pass on amendment
zero four four five h
in the second
representative
now we're back in business all right
representative thomas to talk about the
rem the amendment
uh thank you mr chair once again uh my
name is uh doug thomas from londary
rocky m5 uh vice chair of the science
tech and energy committee
uh
as uh the wish of the committee uh
amendment zero four four five h if you
look on line 28 the recommended change
one
was made it now reads one member of the
senate appointed by the president of the
senate
and that was the change
any other changes
not on this amendment uh
i think we covered the other changes
that have not changed yes okay fine
all right on amendment
oh is there anyone who wishes to speak
on the amendment
seeing none
on the amendment the adoption of the
amendment
045h
will the clerk please call the roll
yes yes
yes
motion passing 21 to zero is that on
consent
oh excuse me
oh i'm sorry you're right
yeah i know
well actually the amendment is the bill
if you look at it uh
okay on the motion about the pass
excuse me um yeah you do have we do have
a motion about to pass as amended
house bill
zero
one zero zero five
uh i am remaking you're going to make
the motions
oops
we passed the amendment
yeah but the original motion was ought
to pass as amended wasn't it
chair will accept the motion about the
pass as amended
thank you
motion ought to pass as amended
on one zero zero five
seconded
seconded by representative kelly is
there a
is there any discussion on the bill as
amended
seeing none
well clerk please call the role
yes
no objections good said it is
and then thank you very much
close the hearing on one zero zero five
all right
that was painful
let's open the hearing on house bill
1520 house bill 1528
establishment the public establishing a
public boat
access donation program for operators of
non-motorized
boats and requiring the fish and game
department to prepare a report
relating to
such a program
there is an amendment
uh
there's no amendment
i thought there was a
amendment to that yeah there is a small
amendment to that
that bill i'm going to now have to grab
the bill but there there is a small
amendment so
representative
i'd like to make a motion to ought to
pass with the bedmin
okay i'd like to speak to my motion when
appropriate all right uh
first i gotta get to
get out the amendment
well
you can do well you can go uh out the
past but then we then uh
yeah
yeah put out the author my apologies
i meant to say ought to pass
we have a motion about to pass and
it's now available to amendment
oh
for second
second by representative
motion is ought to pass
is open to amendment
there
is
i know there is one
yep
yeah i got it now yep
0051h
on the amendment is there a
is there a motion on the amendment
5h
mr chair i'd like to make headline
representative
i'd like to make a motion to
abend
and the most and the amendment is zero
zero five h
apologize i don't have it in front of me
and is there a second to the motion to
on the amendment
second by representative representative
smith
any discussion on the amendment
seeing
representative smith on the amendment
i just wanted to uh say that the
amendment
on the original bill just deletes
section one
uh which which would require a
report submitted to the fishing game and
the resources
and the fish and game committee that
describes how the donation program has
been implemented and its success in
raving raising revenue and it replaces
and so therefore it just
means that the work needs to be done and
the report doesn't need to be done
thank you which is
anyone else to speak on the amendment
if not
on the amendment
zero zero five one eight shall the clerk
please call the roll
yes
okay on the motion about the pass as
amended
i don't i don't think you need a motion
to
we have already amended
it yeah
so an ocean motion of ought to pass as
amended
any discussion
mr chair
yes
just in speaking to my motion from
originally this is a very smart bill
it's a voluntary program that
importantly lets car top boat owners
share in the cost of making sure that
our boat launches are maintained not
just putting the reliance on boat owners
who pay for repairs and maintenance
through their registration but allows
voluntarily
canoers and kayakers to support the
maintenance of our boat launches and our
car tops and we think that helps build a
community of those who love the water
thank you
anyone else wish to speak on the motion
block to pass as amended
representative smith yeah thank you mr
chair
this
bill has come as the result of a lot of
work by a lot of people over the years
to try to
encourage
some payment
by
those who use our state's waters and our
boat accesses our car top accesses
and have non-motorized uh boats usually
kayaks canoes
paddle boards
and this being a volunteer program based
on a similarity to the hike safe program
which is raising more money than a fish
and game at first thought it ever would
i think is a good step
without requiring
payment but through voluntary donations
to
help improve our public water access
sites in the state
anyone else wish to speak
seeing none
on the motion of ought to pass as
amended
on house bill 1528
the clerk please
call the roll
thank you representative yes
yes
kelly yes
consent
seeing no objection to the consent
calendar
and
i might as well uh
i'll be going back at the end of the
meeting and makes certain everybody who
has made motions will be writing
the blurbs
gonna get away guys
okay
and
next is
house bill
first of all close 15 28 open 16 18
which is adding several perfluorinated
chemicals to a list of perfluorocam
alkyl substances with minimum
contaminant level i'm not going to go on
but you can read it at your leisure
uh
well the chair recognizes representative
healy for a motion
do we motion as an interim study on this
is there a second
a second mr chair second by
representative harp
representative healey
would you like to speak to your motion
yes
um
as the emerging science comes forward on
this and as des has
told us
and stated the studies are going on on
ongoing on this that i think we should
let them do their job and let the
go forward with
the science as it comes forward
representative harb would you like to
speak to your second
thank you mr chair i believe uh as my
fellow representative stated we could
gather a lot by putting this into
interim study because of the emerging
technology and i second his motion
so anyone else wishes to speak to the
motion
if not
the motion of
in
interim study
will the clerk please call the role
yes
representative
it's not see with no without objection
it's on the consent calendar
and finally the last on the list even
though it is an early bill
yes
house bill
1641 relative to vessel registration
fees
so anyone wish to make a motion
rep representative smith i will make a
motion uh interim study on house bill
with anyone second the motion
representative huff for a second
would you like to
would you like to speak to your motion
representative smith yes thank you mr
chair um
house bill 1641 would change the way
that
uh
vessels boats on our waterways
pay their registration
and this formula change
would
mean that if you were
owned and bought a new
personal watercraft slash jet ski and
paid fifteen thousand dollars for it
your registration fee would go from
twenty four dollars a year to two
hundred and seventy dollars a year and
if you bought a new pontoon boat for
sixty thousand dollars and your current
registration fee is 52 dollars it would
go up to over a thousand dollars for the
first year and then uh incrementally go
down
based on the
age of the boat
and
although our
registration fees are fairly low
uh this is a huge jump so although
there is definitely room to increase our
vessel registration fees
this this is a little it needs a lot
more work this bill is not ready for
prime time however on the other hand we
heard from captain dunleavy at marine
patrol
that because our registration fee is
separate from the add-ons the money that
goes to fish and game the money that
goes to protect our lakes from aquatic
invasive species and and plants
the federal government is asking and
requiring us to
integrate this into one registration fee
with the
fees the add-on fees not being separated
from registration so i
made the motion for interim study so
that the committee could work on this
and try to
assist marine patrol in getting to a
point that possibly we can come up with
legislation that will be introduced next
year that will help the marine patrol
to actually get this job done and get
the feds off our backs
to be blunt
representative huff for to speak on your
second
i uh concur wholeheartedly with uh
my colleague from grafton county
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
on the uh
on the motion
function of uh
interim study
seeing none will the clerk please call
the role
yes
consent
uh mr chair because of the fiscal note
um does it does it can it go on consent
uh
yeah we're not spending it if you're
going
yeah it's another study so
i don't i don't think it i think it's
okay
with that
it looks well before i before i
bang the gavel to close the executive
session first i want to make certain uh
people who signed up who made motions
are going to
write the blurbs
i still use that old and ancient term
even though they attempt to change me
but
can't do that
you know not only can you can't teach an
old dog new tricks you can't even hardly
get them to walk
uh
okay
uh on uh
uh harvey bullio you uh on the uh
uh on
the
the uh
the uh 1220
which is the
the
docking of the docks on perkins
representative gottling
and uh and uh
uh huff uh for the minority
uh
the
winnipesaukee
that
that is uh
tough as well
uh
on 1418
it's
representative post
uh
on fourth on the
1415 the submerged logs that is
representative huff as well
on the d-e
on the renaming
renaming des 1452
that's representative smith
28 representative with
that's representative egan
1618 representative
healy and
uh it's uh
1641 that's uh representative smith
do i have it am i all correct
everybody signed up
uh
could
could i have them say
saturday
saturday is that too much
saturday by one o'clock before we start
again
by one o'clock
hey i'm kidding
hey look it's had a tough day for me
you know i apologize
i apologize to the members of the
committee because uh
i've had a rough it's been a rough week
hey tom brady should never have retired
but that's what happens when you
it's too much for an old man to take
i'll be
i'll be back on my game next time around
i'll
go in the meeting is adjourned
or the executive session is adjourned
and we will have a meeting just to start
back up at
where
was the
is that one o'clock yeah at one at one
o'clock we'll start here
again
so have a long lunch
you
and
and um there are burgeoning great
grandchildren
they're involved
to
do it right
yeah
is
a pretty good yeah
he built all
these things
okay
you know very very
yes
there are some out there
i used to teach following the procedures
okay
yes
it was wrong
is
uh
here
huh
well at least the chairs are comfortable
sort of i had nice suits
you have one nice suit
ciao
oh
here we go
yes
it just felt like
on the road
cold
nobody
yes
okay
um
oh
sorry
been in oh yesterday
it's like a bright yellowish
um
place
okay
please
something
i repotted um
um
thank you good afternoon welcome back
and welcome to all those new visitors
i'd like to now open the hearing on
house bill
1109 and i recognize the prime sponsor
representative renzullo representative
ronsolo thank you
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
uh this bill is
house bill 1109 relative to approval
for the approval for off highway
recreational vehicles on class 5 and
class 6 roads
right now
a city or town council or boards of
selectmen which are the administrative
bodies of the towns
they authorized the use of class 5 and
class 6 roads
for use by ohrvs which is off highway
recreational vehicles
this bill shifts the authority
authorizing authority to the legislative
branch in other words the town meeting
in the recent past that this committee
has heard from residents complaining of
the process of approval
for ohrv use on roads by the
approval process by the boards of
selectmen
we have we heard stories
of meetings stacked with out-of-towners
or poor notification
all this bill does is give the property
owners access
to a town-wide electorate rather than a
three or a five-person board
also the notification is generally
superior for town meeting items and for
board of selection selectmen's agendas
and also you know
that
selectmen
do
have a say
even in
town
with things that could happen at town
meetings in other words they make
recommendations to the warren articles
so they will get their
their their uh two cents worth in
if you look closely at the bill
you'll see that
the
uh and if you look at the bill itself
you'll see that
item a
which is existing law
is
very similar to item b which is the
edition
uh you'll see it keeps much of the same
text as above
all it does is it just changes the
wording
to allow
the uh
the
the legislative body the town meetings
to make
to make the judgment and the
and not the uh
board of selectmen for those specific
uh those specific roads
and that's my testimony on this
fairly simple
thank you representative any questions
for the representative
representative uh wrong
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question just a clarification
representative zulo on line 22
um it says uh
except for the case of an emergency
closure by a vote of the legislative
body i'm assuming that's still a
majority of the legislative body
uh yes okay thank you
any more questions representative smith
thank you mr chair
um
the
this bill would change it so the select
board do not make the final decision
but there's still the public hearing and
there i mean there's still the public
hearing prior to the vote
and
would the same process be used to
reverse
the decision if a town did allow
ohrv use on the class five and classics
roads that they would the the
legislative body would have to
uh pass the uh to reclose
the road again yeah yes right it's it's
actually is a it
does mimic
the uh
existing law
where and it's it says
such town or city
authorities may change the allowable
usage of a class five or six clear
highway by ohrv use by giving
notification to the supervisor of the
bureau and removing signs
both no longer apply but yes it does uh
say the
still by the vote of the legislative
body
thank you
any other questions
sing none thank you representative
renzolo
thank you
excuse me
our next speaker will be chris gamash he
opposes the bill
from the 0 8
nh ohva
mr gamache
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
chris gamache i'm a resident of gil
gilmanton new hampshire
um lived in new hampshire all my life
i am a board of director member for the
new hampshire office
vehicle association and i'm here
representing them today in opposition
to house bill 1109
predominantly the legislation would
create an imbalance between the process
of opening and closing class 5 and 6
roads
i prior to my
current role i spent 15 years as the
trails bureau chief for the department
of natural resources i left that
position in 2020
i've been before this committee
for 15 years
working on ohrv legislation
and this topic has come up time and time
again in 2019
uh the legislature passed house bill 591
which added the provisions of a duly
noticed public hearing advertised at
least 14 days in advance in a public
location in the city or town
and notification to a butters by
verified mail to the process by which a
town or city
used to open up their class five or six
roads
um that process has been in place for a
little over a year and where it's being
utilized appears to be working
so the system we think isn't broken and
we don't feel a need for a fix
we do also have concerns
in this section of the legis legislation
that on line 18
of the bill you'll notice that it says
pursuant to rsa 21
53 a city or town may authorize the use
of class 5 and 6 highways however on
line 25 and that's to open
these roads you would have to go to the
legislative body
and the city or town would authorize
however on line 24
pursuant to the same statute such city
or town authorities
may take that authority away
so we believe this actually requires a
legislative
act whether it's sb2 voting or a town
meeting to open roads but that the town
select boards still would have the
authority just to close it without the
same process
so with that i would conclude my
testimony and say that respectfully the
new hampshire off-highway vehicle
association opposes house bill 1109
thank you mr gamache
any questions from mr gamache
seeing none thank you for your testimony
i don't see any other pink cards in
front of me for house bill 1109 is there
anyone here yes ma'am come forward
i found two
this abby
thank you abby
is it on now okay
um
thank you for
filing this bill representative brunzulo
and representative gould
the people who live along roads open
ohrvs will definitely tell you the
system is broken and that
if they and so that
a butters of roads considering
considered for ohrv you should
absolutely be notified
um before they're turned into ohrv
trails and
the legislative body should be involved
it shouldn't be up to two of three
selectmen and i'd also like to point out
that um
to actually give any of these
laws pertaining to ohrv placement the
teeth they need
you need to abolish immunity for ohrv
trail sighting
decisions
right now in gorham
seven households is are suing the town
and the state
to remove the ohrv trails from their
neighborhood
and the judge granted the state
sovereign immunity
and the town immunity
which means that when it comes to where
you put atvs
the bureau of trails doesn't have to
follow the law
and a town doesn't have to follow the
law
so until
you abolish immunity for ohrv trail
sighting decisions
these trails can go anywhere
and the problems will continue
so
thank you for looking into this
the people of new hampshire need your
help
thank you for your testimony do we have
any questions of the witness
seeing none thank you again
the next witness in support of the bill
mr smith
good afternoon uh and thanks for the
time i'm really this is an
administrative matter i sent in an email
testifying in opposition to this bill
yesterday
and i have had a chance to talk to the
sponsor and a couple other people to
learn a little bit more about how it
works so i just wanted to officially say
that i'm in support of this bill
i'm representing myself my name is boyd
smith from concord new hampshire and i'm
a
bicycling aficionado but i just wanted
to go on the record of saying that i'm
in support of 1109.
thank you mr smith any questions for mr
smith
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thanks sir
and now i'll ask again is there anyone
else that wants to speak i think i hit
all the pink cards
seeing none nobody approaching the
witness stand i will close the hearing
on hb 1109.
the next hearing is at 1 45 we'll have a
hearing then at hb 11 28.
yeah
for the record i'm going to ask what the
results of the blue sheet was for 1109.
how many four how many against
what we have four names uh two four one
against
um and one didn't make any selection
do you want the actual names
yes go ahead thank you
jason stock of concord
abbey
evan cowe of gorham
chris
looks like pastoria from easton
and dan bennett of concord
uh there was one no n1 unmarked
which ones were okay so dan bennett was
uh
opposed
christmas story i didn't
check anything
uh abby evan cow was
pro and jason stock is pro
thank you
oh bro okay
good afternoon
gonna call this public hearing back into
session
and open for a hearing house bill 1128
and recognize this prime sponsor
representative renzullo representative
renzolo you have the floor
thank you mr chairman
members of the committee
i'm andy renzullo
i
represent the towns of
uh
hudson and pelham
house bill
1128 is an act relative to the financial
liability for damages caused by ohrv use
of class six roads
in other words if the board of selectmen
allows recreational vehicular use
and a member of saying recreational
vehicular use
on a class six road in the town we'll
have to fix the damage done
to the road
okay why is this an issue
the committee has received complaints in
the recent past where boards of
selectmen have authorized the use
of the class six roads
by off
off highway
recreational vehicles now a class six
road is not maintained by the town
so residents who live on these roads
are unhappy
because the high intensity use of cloud
class six roads by these off highway
recreational vehicles damages the road
and the residents on the road have to
repair the road themselves
is only right and equitable
that if the town
if the board of selectmen creates a
situation that damages
some town citizens the town should make
them whole again
now let's
whack a few of the what ifs or the what
abouts
that's going to happen
when
on this bill
it's a town road you can't stop people
from traveling on it
of course not
you're not using the road for
transportation you're using the road for
transportation
not recreation
and the police aren't stupid if they
spot someone they can they can tell
or going over the mountain to the store
to pick up a loaf of bread
versus somebody who's freewheeling and
spinning and grinning around the area
it's different it's
you know
it again it's for the issue is the
recreational use
not the the
uh not the transportational use of the
road
well uh what about people on the class 6
road who have ohrvs
so what
if they tear up the road they'll have to
be the ones to fix it if the board of
selectmen do not
invite
the in the rest of the world to bring
their ohrv's that's the issue and so the
town would not be liable if they don't
if they
if they don't allow
people from outside the areas
to use their ohrvs on those roads
the idea is to disincentivize
the board of selectmen
from inviting in the rest of the world's
ohrv's
it's not to collect fines
i don't have much else to say
i'll take questions
thank you representative any questions
for representative renzullo
representative creighton
thank you
mr chairman mr chairman um
if the town
pays for the damage on a class 6 road
that they had authorized people to go on
does that change the classification that
road from a class 6 to a class 5 since
they are now
spending money on that road
i have heard that
i have not seen a
uh
[Music]
i have not seen a uh
a statue to that effect i mean
i have but i have looked i haven't found
it but it doesn't say it's not there
uh
so
it's in the best interest of this
selectmen
not
to allow
these the ohrvs on the road
you can
in a in again
in a high intensity
recreational use
thank you any other questions for
representative
seeing none thank you for your testimony
our next witness to testify in
opposition to the bill match grace from
new hampshire municipal association mr
graves
thank you mr chair nate graves for the
new hampshire municipal association we
oppose this bill
we really have two reasons for opposing
this bill the first is that
it would conflict with existing law
current new hampshire law prohibits
municipalities from spending money on
class 6 roads
you see this in various statutes for
example
rsa 229 colon 5 which is the definition
of
highways
the major roads that municipalities use
class five roads
are those that they have a duty to
maintain and known as town roads whereas
class six roads are just simply
classified as all other public ways
and generally are those that would be
not maintained
you also have um references to this in
rsa 231 colon 50
and rsa 231 93
those relate more specifically to
liability provisions
the core of the point is that there are
numerous references throughout the
statutes that clearly exempt
municipalities from a duty to maintain
class six roads and that prohibit them
from spending money on those roads
and that makes it very difficult if not
impossible to actually
do what this bill says which is that the
municipality would have to determine
how the road was damaged because it
could only be using the funds to repair
damage done by ohrvis so for example if
a logging truck went down the road and
caused damage
you know you have to determine what the
difference is betw of that damage
between that logging truck which they
couldn't repair and there wouldn't be a
provision repair
and an ohrv use which they would under
this bill be required to repair
the other concern that we have is that
this bill would undermine the ability to
recover damages from those who actually
damage the road
so there are provisions in statute
uh for example rsa 231 colon 11 which
requires someone who
damages a road to restore it to its
prior condition
and rsa 236 colon
39 which is the civil liability for
damages to road statute there's also
criminal liability to uh for damages to
roads that's generally a purposeful
damage
um so if someone purposely goes out and
digs up the road for example
but in any case if someone goes out and
damages the road the municipality could
accept in
this specific instance of the ohrv
damaging the road
go out and recover that damages so
you know if you have for example a group
of riders who
are going on the road during mud season
and it's an unpaved road that's
obviously going to cause
more damage
than
in other conditions
ordinarily the municipality you know if
this is significant enough to rise the
level of damage
that it will be worth pursuing a court
case over
could go after those specific
individuals
but it would appear under this bill that
that would not be a possibility because
the municipality would now have the
responsibility to repair the road using
their own funds so those are the two
major reasons that we object the bill
and i'm certainly happy to answer any
questions
thank you mr grace i
without
first opening it up for questions can
you give us that first
sight that you gave the first one i have
the others rsa 229 colon five
and uh it's actually roman six is the
definition for class six roads
thank you
any questions for mr gray
yes mr crichton representative creighton
yes sir thank you i have two questions
um
the first question is under the current
rsas
the selectmen of the town
can authorize ohrv on classics roads
correct
okay second question then is
if they can authorize that
usage
then what they're authorizing under your
under what you've just said is they're
authorizing
other people from other places
to create damage on a road and then
requiring the citizen adjacent to that
road to fix that road how does that make
any sense
well let me let me clarify because i i
wouldn't quite agree with your
characterization
um so any
town road so any class four or five or
six road
is
the way to think about it really is it's
owned by the town so if someone causes
damage to that road
if you want to repair that road you have
to get the town's permission to do that
there's no authorization under the
statutes for the town to spend money on
class six roads per in particular but if
someone who lives on a class six road
wants to repair that they have to go to
the town to get permission that's
different than say a private road where
the people living on it can go repair it
now it's possible that that road might
be classified as an emergency lane and
there's an emergency lane provision
so you you can see that uh often where
you have
a large number of houses along a
classics road and that would actually
authorize the municipality to spend
money on that road regardless of what
what its classification is or whether
it's a private road to maintain it
suitable for passage
um for emergency vehicles so they could
actually there are ways to maintain it
and there are local options to do that
as as far as
uh the authorization for ohrvs go
um
the way i would look at it is the the
same way that the law would look at any
sort of damage you know
if you have
let's say a logging truck go along a
road you know over time a number of
trucks there you know just the ordinary
wear and tear is going to do damage
depending on how the structure of the
road is
that may or may not cause more damage
which is the reason we have a statutory
provision for weight limits so for
example in mud season the uh the
underlying
foundation of the road may not be quite
as stable so you have a weight limit and
if you surpass that weight limit and
cause damage to the road
there are fines and and potentially you
know suits attached to that you don't
see that happen very often because
that's not something that you know an
individual truck is gonna gonna cause a
lot of damage but it might be something
uh with a business with a large number
of trucks going through or a timber cut
or something like that is more often
where you see some sort of penalty
imposed
um so as far as kind of the
authorization goes
um
there's nothing especially special about
ohrvs uh you know they don't necessarily
dig up the road um
i mean it depends really on what the
conditions are and how they're riding
those vehicles but if you're just
traveling along the road um it's
possible that you know they won't cause
any additional damage as compared to
other traffic it's just that you have a
higher number of vehicles along the road
and it's going to be very specific
but you know if somebody's going in you
know doing figure eights and the
ditching or something like that that's
going to undermine the road and cause
more damage and that's more often the
case where you're going to see
the municipality put in effort to
actually try to stop that behavior
because it's going to
cause that unnecessary damage but again
it's it's it's a case-by-case basis
okay thank you
any other questions from mr graves
representative smith
thank you mr chair um thank you for
testifying mr grayson thanks for taking
my testimony um you did you did speak a
while back about um you know the roads
posted in the spring with weight limits
are class six roads posted in the spring
because of the weight limits that's a
individual municipality decision um so
often what you'll see is a
road agent for the municipality will go
out assess each road in the town and
sometimes they're just roads that are
always have a weight limit for the
spring but it's something that's made on
an a decision that's made on an annual
basis by the select board
follow-up yes um
you
and i want to make sure i heard this
correctly but
you did say that class four five and six
roads are owned by the town
that's the way i think about them um in
the sense that the town has all the
rights to
the road itself they may not necessarily
own the land underneath the road so it's
technically a road is technically a
viatic easement so an easement that
allows the public to travel over and do
other things
that relate to traveling along that road
um and there's a
a large number of case law from the
1800s about that um and feeding horses
and all of that but um
really the way to think about it is that
the town owns the road in the sense that
it's the select board
under their authority to manage the
roads
have the authority to determine what
happens to those roads whether it's you
know allowing ohrvs to use it or whether
you know
i don't know you have a horse and
buggies going along it whatever the case
may be
um it's the the select board that's
allowed to make that decision under our
statutory scheme
one more
all right
um
my last question
is you did mention there were local
options to repairing these class six
roads
correct i wondered what
what those would include because
i haven't heard anything from people
i've talked to who all live on classics
roads right so
one of the the really the major option
that the municipality would have is
declare it as an emergency lane and
essentially they would they would need
to have a public hearing and it's
generally either the fire chief or the
police chief that comes
and specifies why this needs to be an
emergency lane because
they're the ones who provide the
emergency services so they'll come in
and say you know there's 20 houses at
the end of this road it's a private road
or it's a class six road
you know we can't maintain it but we
need to get the fire truck down there in
case there's a fire or whatever the case
may be or the road leads to the pond and
we need to fill up the fire truck um and
so that's something the municipality has
the option of doing
and that provides them the ability to
maintain the road to the standard of
being able to be traveled by the
emergency vehicles
you have
you know you could always have the town
reclassify a road as a class five road
and there are a number of options to do
that and
i'd bore you to tears if i went through
those um but you could always do that
and then maintain it um
and if you stop maintaining the class
five road
in a condition suitable for travel for
five or more years then then it reverts
to a class six road so i mean you have
options of different things you could do
at the local level
um
to to require municipal maintenance
um which would not require any sort of
investigation of of who caused the
damage um if that's an option that you
want to pursue
thank you
any other yes
representative thank you mr chair thank
you for taking my questions i just want
to get some clarity so i may have a
question and follow up
so you said that the
slick board
can periodically review the weight
limits
to adjust the weight limits for the
damage that might come from trucking on
roads correct
so
would they also be able to then
review
the damage there since that so because
they're doing that their the town is
then responsible or controlling their
responsibility for the damage that might
come to the roads
if a select board is now a current
statute allowed to allow ohrvs to travel
on the road wouldn't they be needing to
take the same responsibility
to maintain those roads from ho or hrv
travel
i
i don't believe so because
with a weight limit you're looking at
something like um
you know if you take the road in front
of the state house here which they
recently repaired
before it was repaired it may be the
case that you know it was the end of its
life uh usable life and therefore it was
necessary for the concord city council
to put a weight limit on it um and that
would have
effectively either prevented large
trucks from going down it
or
they would have paid the penalty for
doing so assuming it was enforced all
the time
and that's going to change based on the
conditions of the road
you know
once it's been repaved you don't
necessarily have to do that and it's not
required that you review every road for
a weight limit
it's an it's a it's an option and you're
going to attach those to things
where that type of activity is going to
cause
damage
thank you
no follow-up
any other questions for the witness
yes representative perez
thank you for letting me ask the
question thank you for taking my
question my question to you is um
if we have in a situation where
it's a residential area and
you see people coming from other streets
and then
driving their
hrvs in the area that
only vehicles supposed to be
how are we gonna handle the situation if
the role get damaged by the hrbs because
the people who damage and death the role
is not from not living on the street
that this is you know happening
how did that situation get handled
right so
if i understand your your question
correctly
i mean the way i would analogize it is
you know when they built the road they
would have they would have had certain
requirements and if you look at
something like the dots geometric design
standards they would say you know you
look at the road and you figure out how
many average you know
average times a car or other vehicle is
going to go over the road and that's
going to that's going to give you the
result of how you want to build the road
and if you suddenly convert something
like a residential road to
a cut-through
as has frequently happened with
something like google maps
you're going to see a lot more traffic
over the road than you would otherwise
and that's
i don't have a good solution for you
because you certainly see that in many
different
circumstances but i i think
you know that's really something that
they have to determine at the local
level determine what is the appropriate
nature maybe the case that they want to
convert that to a class 5 road and
therefore have the municipality take
over responsibility for it
that would be the cleanest way under the
current uh statutory scheme
sir another question to my right any
other questions yes representative post
thank you mr vice chair and thank you
again for today for coming to testify um
my question is very simple i wanted to
know you had talked about someone who
purposely digs up a roadway
do you have that
rsa i i don't have off the top of my
head the uh the criminal damage to
rhodes but i can certainly look that up
and give that to you by the end of the
hearing thank you
any other questions for the witness
seeing none thank you mr grace for your
testimony thank you
next in support of the bill and excuse
me if i mispronounce your last name abby
evander
ivanko thank you abby
uh thank you
and um
again i i have to emphasize
i appreciate you're all looking into
this problem that's statewide
and also you need to know that right now
the attorney general's office is
actively defending the bureau of trail's
right to ignore the laws that govern
where ohrv trails are allowed so we've
got all these trail sighting
requirements
and
the attorney general is saying well
bureau of trails doesn't have to follow
them and they're also saying that the
town of gorham doesn't have to follow
them our own zoning our noise ordinance
you don't have to follow them
so
when you
file these bills to address the ohrv
problem
please consider
adding in
the abolishing of immunity for ohrv
trail citing decisions
by the municipalities and the state
and that will give the teeth that these
desperately needed bills
need
when they become law
thank you thank you for your time and
concern
thank you any questions for the witness
seeing none thank you for your testimony
next also on in opposition to the bill
chris gamash nhoh
mr gamache
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record again my name
is chris gamache my resident of
gilmanton new hampshire and i'm on the
board of directors of the new hampshire
off highway vehicle association
uh and we are here
in opposition of house bill 1128
i'll be very brief i won't belabor what
the new hampshire municipal association
discussed which was some of our concerns
but we believe creating this simple
section
in the ohrv laws would actually conflict
with at least four other existing
statutes that would also have to be
looked at and addressed
otherwise this bill simply creates more
confusion and questions than it
clarifies
um
this bill also creates the same
subsection in law as house bill 1108 it
would both be creating a new subsection
b
under roman numeral nine
so if both bills were to move forward
they would actually be in conflict with
each other and that would have to be
clarified
and we believe that the changes sought
in this legislation are far more
complicated than adding one
subsection
that require rewrite of many laws we
believe potentially unintended
consequences of such a revision to our
existing laws requires a much more
thorough review
and we believe that some of these
questions are better suited toward house
bill 1188's proposed study commission
which
i'll be up shortly to support
so we think a lot of these questions
should be routed
toward that study commission
with that i'll end my testimony thank
you
thank you mr gamache any questions from
mr gamache
seeing none thank you for your testimony
i have no more pink cards is there
anyone else that would like to speak on
11 28
i see some hands so come forward
we got it
mr stock to speak in support of the bill
are you ready
okay well good afternoon for the record
i'm jason stock i'm the executive
director of the new hampshire timberland
owners association our members own
timberland
and
over which class six roads pass
and a but
and we i come here today in in support
of this bill
um
and i i want to explain to you kind of
why why we're engaged in this discussion
um timber and timberland
the value of timber and timberland is
driven much by access you've got a tree
growing in the forest its value in many
instances predicated by the ability to
get that tree to market roads and
infrastructure in maintaining roads and
infrastructure are important and they
they have a direct effect on timber
values and timberland values
and if that road and infrastructure
deteriorates and it becomes impassable
that affects your value and your ability
to
your values and also your ability to do
management on your property
um class six roads as you've heard from
the municipal association
they're they're an important part of the
state's infrastructure they're municipal
roads the towns own the right-of-way the
landowners own underneath the road
but the towns do have the authority to
the authority to manage the right-of-way
over top of it they can and they have in
their toolbox within the road statute a
bunch of tools to do that
they can post a road for weight limits
as you've heard
they can also require bonds
if you're going to use a road
and this is frequent in the timber
business if i'm go i file my intent to
cut and i'm going to travel across the
road the road agent will say okay mr
stock you're going to be driving some
large trucks on our road we would like
you to post a bond in the event that one
of your trucks harms the road
we have a financial financial surety
here to repair that road so that you
don't just skip town
and now we're stuck with a road that's
that has has
problems um
so there there are a number of of tools
that and abilities to do that class six
roads are subject to gates and bars
although they don't typically put locks
on them they do have gates and they they
can be subject to gates and bars as well
this is a subject that i have to and it
usually happens right around march 1st
my phone starts ringing as road postings
go up and i have loggers trying to move
wood out of the woods
uh to the mill um and they're talking
and working with road agents my phone
starts to ring
and you know we try to find amicable
solutions and ways to work through this
so that people can get their wood to the
market um
one of the one of the reason
i'll say more recent wrinkles that we're
seeing is with roads and class six roads
in particular in recreational use
so if i'm if i have a road
a class six road that's accessing my
property
many times these roads are are very
almost impassable to a standard vehicle
and therefore
if i as a landowner or a land manager
logger or forester want to go in and do
a timber sale and do some management on
that land i'm obligated i can't legally
touch that right of way until i get
authority from the selectmen so i'll go
to the selectmen and say selectmen this
is what we're going to do can i have
authority to do this
and
most times most often they'll say
absolutely go ahead and do it it's my
money that i invest in that road if i
have to bring gravel in if i have to
bring phil if i have to put an excavator
out there to smooth things out or a
dozer it's my money that i as a private
citizen so the town is not making that
investment it's me as a landowner and of
course that gets built into my timber
sale
in my management work
it's also not uncommon to have the town
say okay thank you for that oh by the
way we'd like you to also bond that i've
gotten calls from loggers saying how
does this work i just sent spent thirty
thousand dollars and now they want me to
bond it
my biggest incentive here not to damage
it is the fact that i just dropped
thirty thousand dollars but we pay the
bond because it's it is a legal right
that the towns have and
we we go about our business
what gets frustrating is
i go to i have to go to the selectmen i
have to get approval
i put my money into the road i actually
then in some instances have to ensure
that with a bond
there are instances where perhaps a road
posting gets a posting gets posted so i
can't use it during mud season
yet that road continues to see
other traffic
and i've had more than and i could have
paraded in landowners and foresters
today to give you many stories of where
i've gone through this process to watch
my investment literally get washed down
the road
because of use during particularly
sensitive times of the year
mud season where the road is sensitive
we're going to stay off it
but
an individual decides it might be pretty
cool to see if they can make it up that
hill
and uh as a result create a pair of ruts
that erode and wash out
so our interest in this bill
is is one that we look at and we say all
right
you know
we're
we have a set of rules and guidelines by
which we operate on
we've we've worked with those for for
hundreds of years
um but there are other users out there
and you know we're making investments in
this infrastructure we're doing what we
should be there are other users out
there that may not have the the inves
clearly not the financial investment
and for us there seems to be an inequity
there
and i will grant you um
when we looked at this piece of
legislation
um and i applaud the sponsors efforts
probably the the best place for this to
land would have been it within the road
statutes as you heard from the municipal
association
because there's a whole body of law that
deals with roads road classifications
when they switch etc
and i also appreciate the fact that as a
municipality they're not going to want
to make the investment in the road
um
they're not going to want to make the
investment because as was discussed
earlier it does it will revert to a
class 5 road and as a result the town
then is hung with that obligation to
maintain it
um
henceforth
but
inasmuch as we wanted to come today and
kind of ex lay out this issue we do
think there may be some opportunities in
opportunities to do this it may be in
the context of the study commission it
may be in the context of this bill
where
perhaps you have a road if you have a
local club that wants to use a class six
road as a trail say all right
adopt a trail you folks have adopted it
it's on you
you can you can post a bond
you can maintain it
and that way the town's not on the hook
but yet you have some stewards there
that have a have a vested interest in
that trail and even perhaps a financial
interest if a bond is required and say
all right just like you do with your
other trails
in other networks perhaps that's a
solution
and i would i would offer that as a
suggestion
because
again what we're seeing now
you know the frustration out there
amongst landowners and land managers can
get pretty great when they've
made these investments they have
followed the rules they're doing what
they should
and
then to have it kind of literally wash
away
again we support the bill i will admit
it it probably needs some work
either where it sits statutorily
but and
some other minds may need to come to
bear and kind of think this through so
that towns aren't automatically getting
on the hook of having to maintain roads
by inadvertently
having them classified as a class five
road but
um i offer that as my testimony today
i'd be happy to
answer any questions and certainly happy
to work with you folks
in the future on this issue as
it is uh it is a significant issue for
for our membership thank you
thank you for your testimony any
questions from mr stack
representative smith
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
stock for taking my question
um you mentioned that you thought that
some work could be done on this and it
could possibly be ready for prime time
um do you see that that could be done in
one or two work sessions or is it going
to require more than that
i given the complexity of roads
and there are literally books
books written on roads in road law
one to two set one to two work sessions
might be a bit optimistic
i i wish we could
but it there is uh this gets it is a can
of worms but it is it is an important
issue
thank you
any other questions
i i have one question you mentioned
about
clubs
adopting a road
do you know can a board of selectmen
approve a class six road for ohrv
subject to the condition that a club
adopted
representative harp that is a that's a
great question and i don't know it was a
it was a suggestion that was put forth
by one of my committee members
it's been a model that's worked really
well with the snowmobile industry where
you have clubs and club networks
that maintain trails police trails and
maintain positive landowner relations
and so one of the thoughts was
if that may be if you have a model there
that works perhaps this is another model
that we could try to use and adopt it to
the ohrv
community as well
thank you
see no other hands thank you very much
for your testimony
did we miss anybody else's great pink
card
yes
come forward
you could have
boyd smith i live in concord new
hampshire and i thought i'd put a card
up there yes you did it was hidden so
this is kind of that administrative
thing again i sent the email yesterday
uh in
opposition um i'd like to change that
officially to support
um but i've got to say after listening
to this expert testimony of a few people
in front of me that really know this
business
there's clearly an awful lot to unpack
or actually pack in
i think what i wanted to say i like the
idea of my understanding the intention
of the bill to link
a
municipal decision with a municipal
responsibility that simple understanding
is if you open it and the town you know
it has some
authority to
to manage that road versus right now we
can't put money into classics as my
understanding but that being said it's
clearly clearly a complicated situation
and i'm also looking at 1188 you know as
a broader opportunity to study what
really is a statewide
broad-based issue and i won't even say a
problem but there's multiple users on
multiple you know rail trails and
classics roads
and i think
take a good careful look at that with
all the stakeholders that need to be at
the table
so we can figure out some of these
complexities to maintain our you know
our recreational systems our classics
public transport systems
uh really makes a ton of sense so i'm uh
supporting the attention of the bill
understanding that this concept probably
needs a bigger
uh a bigger venue and a bigger forum
to
to put it to practice so
thank you very much for your time
thank you mr smith any questions from mr
smith
seeing none thank you for your testimony
mr gray's maybe have that site for us i
i do um it's rsa 236 colon 38
it it states that a uh criminal damage
to roads is a misdemeanor
um with a
intent of
without authority someone willfully
injures the road essentially
and since i'm up here i'll just add that
i did like mr stock's suggestion and i'm
more than happy to work with anyone on
on that
project
thank you representative posted you have
a question yes can you clarify the
number again was it rsa 236 colon 6
colon 38 38 thank you
thank you thank you mr
is grays
anyone else to testify on house bill
yes come forward
have you filled out a pink card that we
can't find uh no i didn't but i did fill
uh online
submitted testimony written testimony
my name is stephen wilke i'm president
of sullivan county atv club in clermont
new hampshire
we've been in existence since 1999 and
have worked with the city of clermont
the town of cornish and the town of
newport and in the last two years we've
put in over fifty thousand dollars worth
of grant aid funds into class five and
class six roads within our two towns uh
i encourage you to read my testimony on
this bill and the one i submitted
earlier
as great examples of how things can work
and
there is certainly
the ability for a municipality to grant
permission to a club to maintain those
roads and we have been doing it the
right way for many years
thank you mr wilkie um but before you
leave can you fill out a pink card so
the clerk can have it any questions from
mr wilkie
yes
representative
kelly
mr wilkie um so there was the question
earlier about whether
uh if a club puts a trail on their trail
map are they responsible is there a
legal responsibility to to maintain that
trail or maintain that road so when we
get a permission slip uh which comes
from the bureau of trails
we are growing
to maintain sign and keep in safe
condition
these trails and roads
often times in municipality the road is
already open to ohrvs like in cornish
those roads have been open since the
their early 70s
and
they just then
extend permission to our club by written
you know indefinite and then when we
need to do work on it we go back they
fill out a form for the maintenance and
then we can apply for grant aid or we
pay for it ourselves
oftentimes the trucks the 4x4 trucks
that go over these roads
because they're legally registered do
more damage than our small machines our
machines the largest ones are two
thousand pounds
last year eversource used cat whole road
and they totally ruined the road uh and
and our club actually had to go in and
use our funds to fix it and then we got
washed out with the summer rains and we
had to go fix it again
and
we have the capability because of the
membership program and the grant aid
program
thank you any other questions from mr
wilkie
yes just to remind you mr wilkie can you
fill in the card thank you
anyone else to testify on house bill
1128.
i'll ask one more time anybody else to
testify 11 28
seeing no one approaching the mic i'll
before i close the hearing do we have
anybody on the blue sheets
yes representative who do we have
my apologies to uh whoever's name i'm
about to butcher for the second time
today
uh we have three names two four one
against the two 2-4 would be abby evanco
and chris story and the one against
would be dan bennett
thank you
having heard that i will close this
hearing the next hearing
starts now
next hearing that it will open uh house
bill 1188
bill to establish a commission to study
ohrv use in the state
as she heads to the
witness table i'll recognize the prime
sponsor representative smith when she
gets there
i do have three pink cards
more common
so i now have five pink cards including
representative smith
let me get organized here
okay thank you mr chair thank you
committee good to see you all on the i
can now see everyone's faces as opposed
to your backs
um great to be here um for the record i
am suzanne smith i'm state
representative from grafton county
district 8 representing the towns of
hebron plymouth and holderness and i am
here as the prime sponsor of house bill
and of course i am in support of it
but i want to just talk a little bit
about ohrvs in general so you know why i
have introduced this bill the first
bills related to ohrvs in new hampshire
were introduced in 1989.
since then 57 laws related to ohrvs have
been signed into law
since the first bill was introduced atvs
as they were called then usually had
three wheels and held one passenger
the variety and size of these
recreational vehicles has expanded to
include four-wheelers utvs utility
terrain vehicles
gators like tractors side by sides which
hold four people and dirt bikes they are
now commonly referred to as off-highway
recreational vehicles and they are
bigger and wider they than they were
even 10 years ago
sales and use have expanded
exponentially
as have concerns by law enforcement
landowners whose property abuts trails
and roads the tourism industry and those
who share rail trails with ohrvs
members of this committee over the year
have had the opportunity to ride on and
drive ohrvs on field trips to jericho
mountain state park in berlin and the
surrounding environs including riding on
highways through the town the city of
berlin
the legislature has been instrumental in
passing laws which take small bites out
of some of the challenges that we have
recognized but as you know deadlines for
committee work do not allow for a deep
dive into the many issues confronting
law enforcement landowners
municipalities the department of
transportation bureau of trails and
legislators
as well as riders
in august of 2021 a group of
stakeholders including legislators
executive councilor joe kenny law
enforcement the new hampshire bureau of
trails and the president of the new
hampshire ohrv association
came together and brainstormed about
ongoing concerns related to ohrvs
and i have distributed that article that
was in the paper that talked about that
meeting to all the
committee members
counselor kenny suggested a commission
which could work long term to try to
solve some of the challenges and this
bill came out of that meeting
so what will the commission do
if you look at page
two of the no page one of the bill there
is a list no that's members never mind
page two
talks about some of the duties which the
commission will study and current cur
including current statutes related to
ohrvs which some of them conflict with
each other because of all the many many
bills that have been passed into law
over the last
30 years
positive and adverse effects of ohrv use
on state and town roads how fish and
game departments state police county
sheriffs and municipal
police work together to provide
consistency and enforcement
education and safety requirements for
ohrv riders which we had a bill last
week about
a positive and adverse effect on the
economy of ohrvs and the impacts of
requiring rental agents to install speed
regulating governors on ohrv's provided
to renters
and of course the all all other issues
which come before the commission
so this it's a huge charge it's not
an easy fix it's going to take quite a
while which is why it is a five-year
commission and not a two-year or
one-year commission
because
to make it any shorter than five years
would just not allow the time needed to
review
i mean the two bills we just heard the
safety bill we had uh last week
the education bill we had last week all
of these are just little bites of the
apple
so i have received a lot of input from
people um requesting changes to the
commission membership
and i did pass out a
possible amendment it hasn't been
submitted yet because i expect it may be
tweaked a little bit more even and that
gives you
a number of people on all sides of the
issue whether they're ohrv clubs the
bureau of trails members of the public
landowners
conservation commission i mean and the
rail trail coalition so i tried to
include
a lot of stakeholders so a really good
discussion can happen out of this
commission
and i hope that you will support it and
i can try to answer any questions and
also to actually add to the safety issue
i did pass out um
september 21 crash reports from fish and
game and almost all of them are due to
inexperience
and speeding and not obeying the current
laws and
then you also have recklessness too but
these are all things that kind of turned
my head and made me think we really have
to do something and the legislator who
uh brought together the stakeholders in
august
is one of the co-sponsors of this bill
and two of the other legislators who
were at that meeting are also
representatives kelly and egan
so thank you
thank you representative any questions
for representative smith
yes representative iran
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um you mentioned
representative smith this is a five-year
commission
but on the bill it says that it uh it
will be repealed in 2026 so um i think
of that as four years well it's november
of 2026 so i guess it's four and a half
okay
follow-up thank you um the other thing
on your proposed amendment
um on item number 13 you say one
representative of the new hampshire
society for the protection of forest the
appalachian mountain club or the nature
conservancy
so are you suggesting one member from
each of those no no it's or not and so
it's they will work together and they
will come up with one person who would
represent their interests okay i
understand thank you and we're i'm still
working on a better wording for that
any other questions from representative
smith
i did have one um
the uh the number 11 the timberland
owners i've just received information
that the way that uh timberland owners
and the farm bureau would like to be
combined would be one representative
representing landowners
chosen by the to timberland owners and
the new hampshire farm bureau
so that would just
doesn't change the number
thank you representative
no questions thank you for your
testimony
thank you
next witness in favor
abby evenco abby
again thank you very much for looking
into this issue
i would request i i agree with changing
the um
the commission makeup so it's more
representative of of a more diverse
makeup of new hampshire citizens
and also when you're looking into the
impact of requiring speed regulators
also
noise regulators for the people who are
anywhere near these machines
the noise is a big problem
so i'd like you to consider that and
again
abolishing immunity for the town and
state
thanks for looking into this
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
also speaking in favor chris gamash
n-h-o-h-v-a mr gamache
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee again my name is chris kamasch
from gilmanton new hampshire board of
directors for the new hampshire off
highway vehicle association
we are here testifying in support of
house bill 1188 it is supported by all
28 of our member clubs it's officers and
directors
we'd like to thank representative smith
for introducing this she's been involved
in these topics certainly with this
committee for a number of years
speaking
on behalf of myself
i attended the hearings on the first atv
study commission when i was hired by the
bureau of trails in 2001 and i've been
attending hearings before the rrd
transportation other committees ever
since
and i would agree we've passed
legislation about
study committees study commissions that
have lasted roughly the summer
before the next legislative season maybe
two years
and they have not done what is needed to
be done a term approach is needed for
these discussions there are a lot of
topics as you have heard and seen
between legislation proposed last week
and this week
so the new hampshire off highway vehicle
association wholeheartedly supports the
passage of house bill 1188
we would like to see any proposed
amendment
and one concern would be how big the
list of attendees gets the larger a
commission gets the more ineffective it
becomes
and we would have concerns with adding
more and more people that
would likely make it no longer a
balanced and fair commission uh with
that i'll end my testimony and thank you
for your time thank you mr gamache any
questions for mr gamache
seeing none
yes representative crichton
thank you mr chairman mr kamasha
since 2001 you've been on several
commissions what would have been the
results of those commissions
and
have those commissions provided value or
are they just
taking up oxygen uh thank you for the
question representative creighton so
some of them have provided value um i
can't remember the house bill number
from 2001
it was representative alger
from romney
who filed that study commission
we worked with other you know the
basically off iowa vehicle bureaus from
the other surrounding states to learn
what they had done
had all their states come in we looked
at
a host of draft documents the state at
that time had come up with 1998 a draft
a list of considerations that the state
needed to use when they were building
an ohiv trail on state lands it had
never been tested
it actually was then from that
commission put into
a bill house bill 1273 during the
2002-2003 legislative season
and that actually codified this draft
untested criteria in law
and we've had issues with it ever since
um but it did you know put it out that
we had to start looking at public lands
the issue at the time had been really
only private lands were hosting ohrv
trails and private landowners really
wanted to see a balance if they were
going to be asked to only open their
lands their expectation was the state
would do so as well to support some of
these
those early on came out with a lot of
work um we've had some regarding the
roads um you know the house bill
519 i testified to earlier from 2019
adding in the public policy or the
public notice in verified mail to a
butter is on class five and six roads
those were good changes that came out as
well so we have had some
but we really haven't taken a big deep
dive look
in a number of years okay thank you
you're welcome
any other questions
yes representative
thank you mr gamache um could you tell
me our uh the jeeps with the huge tires
classified as ohrvs
and do they go routinely on those trails
so
the answer is it depends
um
they are not
they are off highway recreational
vehicles in new hampshire is an
extremely broad definition and it's
basically anything used off-road with
tires
that is used for enjoyment
you know if you're smiling and you're
not on a paved surface or a road
you technically are in an off-highway
recreational vehicle um so
we have a trail at jericho mountain
state park where only jeeps and
full-size trucks are allowed not atvs
and utvs they are traditionally not
allowed on the other trails that clubs
manage in the state
class six roads though though if they're
registered as a conventional motor
vehicle they're allowed to operate on
those you know as transportation
purposes
questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
our next witness supporting the bill
with an amendment
dan bennett new hampshire auto dealers
association mr bennett
uh
thank you mr chairman and member of the
committee my name is dan bennett with
the new hampshire automobile dealers
association we're a trade association
for the motor vehicle industry in new
hampshire
um i'm here today on behalf of our 40 or
so ohrv dealers snowmobile and atvs
we support the bill and the admiral
goals that representative smith has put
forward
especially around the issue that we
talked about last week of
responsible ridership and proper safety
and rider education um we do um i have
not seen representative smith's
amendment but we would respectfully
request that
nhada or one of its designees be added
as a
commission member
we are the sellers the servicers the
registration agents and the rental
agents of ohrvs we really are on the
front line of these these serious issues
surrounding ohrvi usage
it's also we're in the unique position
due to our manufacture dealer
relationship to get information data and
access on some of the
uh i guess latest and greatest
technology
efficiency and designs that are going
into product and product pipeline as
well so i heard the issue of noise
emission levels certainly something we
would have access to governors we are
rental agents but we're also the
builders of those units so we have great
knowledge on governors for say
the speed limit governor that's proposed
so
with that being said we think our voice
would be beneficial in the commission we
would welcome the opportunity to
participate
and further the goals and the important
studies that the commission is doing
so with that i'd take any questions if
there are any but pretty simple thank
you mr bennett any questions for mr
bennett
think somebody
no i guess thank you mr bennett i
appreciate it
our next witness also speaking in
support of the bill matt leahy forest
society mr lady
hi sorry about that good afternoon my
name is matt leahy i'm the
public policy director for the foreign
society
um i'll be brief um i am
i have written testimony i'm not going
to read that but i would just say very
briefly we support
this legislation
and obviously this committee
has spent quite a bit of time on this
issue in the last three or four years
and there has i think been some helpful
steps as a result of that work but i
think it's also clear that there you
know there are still issues
areas of concern conflict between you
know atv users and non-atv users and so
you know we just think this study
commission um
will help really get to that you know
you know to these issues and as chris
gamache mentioned you know i think now
is the time to really take a deep hard
look at
the whole global picture here in new
hampshire on
on atvs and how we can you know
try to get to the heart of some of these
issues so again we support it and um
thank you i'll have to take any
questions
thank you for your testimony any
questions from mr leahy
seeing none thank you for your testimony
our next witness also in support of the
bill boyd smith representing himself mr
smith
uh thank you again for uh giving me some
time to speak this is not an
administrative change like the first
couple uh
it sent out an email uh late yesterday
in support of hb1188 and i
said with amendments i don't even know
if that's allowed but what i'd like to
do because i wasn't able to pass out
testimony
is uh is i would like to read what i
said it'll take three minutes
and i apologize but i think that's
probably the best use of the time i want
to thank representative smith for
bringing this up
it's clearly an important issue that is
going to take a bunch of people around
the table and some time to get it right
as currently written hb 1188 i think is
overly focused on ohrvs and the northern
part of the state
given the many hundreds of miles of
classics roads and also state-owned
abandoned rail corridors throughout new
hampshire and their hundreds of
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
non-motorized recreational users
the commission's scope should be
expanded
in addition there's an opportunity to
include pending results of the
nhdot rail trail strategic plan i
believe they call it due out this summer
as well as best management practices
being developed under hb 311 which i'm
actually assisting with in a in a
different capacity
so in short hb 1188 provides an
opportunity to contribute to the
effective long-term planning required to
balance multiple competing needs and
uses of state public rights of way for
the benefit of our state
so some of my uh i'll call them
recommended amendments or things that
ask that this committee to consider
is
avoiding on the list of members for the
commission avoiding duplication of
authority
so for example reaching out to a
statewide sheriff a state police
representative
for that level of law enforcement
that there's a members of the public
section that focuses really on the north
country and i understand that's where a
lot of this activity is occurring but i
suggest it's going to be statewide it's
heading that way and why shouldn't it
so members of the public should
represent the entire state not solely
the north country
that representatives for non-motorized
use should be included as members of the
commission
and my suggestion is that the new
hampshire rail trails coalition or the
new hampshire bike walk alliance would
be good associations because they
represent
non-motorized use on a lot of these
trails
i also think that uh representing
the wintertime use snowmobiles
should be included as members of the
commission the snowmobile association i
realize it's seasonal but a lot of use
on the same networks
or at least maybe brought in to testify
because they are experienced
with maintaining trails and and managing
them
section three under duties i've got page
two lines eleven through twelve should
be expanded to include positive and
adverse effects on public rights of way
such as rail trails so adding rail
trades beyond the class six
and uh also the overall compatibility of
our ohrvs with other uses
ohrv and other trail use the
non-motorized side of things
monitoring and enforcement by state
agencies charged with public trail
management and stewardship such as d.o.t
bureau of trails parks and rec
department of cultural natural resources
should also be assessed
my final recommendation a request is
that the quorum which is currently
listed at six
we made a simple majority
and
the reasoning being that this is a large
complicated issue and if we have 18 or
19 people on the commission
and only six can make a decision i think
that
contravenes the effectiveness of the
more diverse group
so i apologize for my lack of time to
speak with the bill sponsors in advance
to learn more about how this could work
and adjust my testimony accordingly i
recommend that hb 1188 be designed as a
comprehensive statewide examination of
how public roads and rights of way can
be shared by the various user
communities so thank you for your
consideration and for the time to speak
thank you mr smith any questions from mr
smith
sing none i thank you for your testimony
thank you sir
what may be our last pink card
in support of the bill jason stock new
hampshire timberlane owners association
timberland owners association
good afternoon i'm jason stock new
hampshire timberland owners i'll i'll be
brief um
we we do te we are testifying in support
of this in support of the study
commission and the language that the
bill's sponsor uh representative smith
had suggested the farm bureau nhtoa
nominating a landowner to to represent
someone who owns working land
that is consistent with other boards and
commissions where we will jointly
nominate a landowner particularly
someone with working land that has a in
this case a trail across it so we
wanted to voice this our support for
this for the bill and for that amendment
as you've heard you heard earlier
ohrv use it's it is an important issue
to our members we have seen a tremend my
members have seen a tremendous uptick
since covid hit
talking to land managers and these are
land managers across the state
they are spending a lot more time
managing recreation these days than they
ever have and it's everything from
you know
policing and monitoring use on the
property picking up trash fixing gates
um
and you know so it's
this this study commission is timely
i appreciate representative creighton's
question about is this just another
study commission but what i would add is
to that is that now more than ever with
this increase in recreation
it is it has become very uh
very acute in
acute
costly for landowners and time consuming
particularly those landowners who have
large tracts of land where
there's a lot of recreation going on
they say the days of just managing
loggers and log trucks
those were the good old days now they're
managing
all kinds of use so
i appreciate the opportunity to testify
in support of this
in support of the the amendment as
suggested and would be happy to answer
any questions
thank you mr stock any questions for mr
stock
i don't see any thank you for your
testimony thank you
anyone else we wishing to speak on house
bill 1188
anyone else
last call anyone else
yes please fill one out before you leave
and give it to the clerk
you need to press the button
there you go
your name
my name is chris pasteriza and i
apologize for my
uninflected
voice
i haven't heard anybody speak for
anything other than people
people say that we will not stay stop
atvs
what does this mean except that those
who want to use atvs have more money and
more support from legislators
than those who do not want atvs used
against them
duty of legislators
this make evidence-based and ethical
assessments and decisions not decisions
or recommendations based on power
the bill and the committee it seeks to
establish should not assume the
permitting of recreational atv use
as a given
atvs damaged terrain
air
soil
water
wildlife plant life and humans
atvs contribute to global warming
recreational atv use is a completely
non-essential use of fossil fuels in the
midst of our climate emergency
the atv issue is a moral issue
most people in this room believe that we
are the most important species
and we have the right to damage other
beings and the law allows it
most people believe humans have the
right to log bulldoze mine
synthesize create buy and consume
whatever we want no matter the
consequences to our environment and
other beings
this belief system is not supported by
any evidence
what supports it is our desperate need
to believe in our self-importance
we are not only no more important than
any other people we are no more
important than any other species
and because we are the most invasive and
damaging species on the planet we have
an obligation to radically reduce our
consumption
of everything
the rational and fair approach to this
is to first cease all non-essential
consumption
atv use like other every other
recreational fossil fuel use is
non-essential
so we have no ethical right to engage in
it
the atv riders and the legislators that
support them honestly looked at the
damage you allow or do to others
if you looked at the non-consensual
nature of your acts
if you inhaled dust others have no
choice but to take into their lungs
you felt the violation of the noise you
ran repeatedly into non-consenting ear
canals
you felt the compression of your
battering of soil that damages it for
years
you understood the dead zone that the
ride the wilds roads are
the fragmentation of terrain the trail's
cause
the pollution and co2 produced by atvs
the abuse of wildlife and trail of
butters
you would then have no choice but to
engage in the self-denial
of not riding
for the good of the whole
those who are exploited and abused by
the permitting of atv use
wildlife the soils watersheds air
climate hikers people in atv towns and a
butters
are not just deprived of the right to
peace
quiet privacy and clean air
they are pushed down into a position
where if they or someone on their behalf
asserted their right not to be abused
but butters for example blocked an atv
trail they would then be
arrested so the atvs are not ma'am can i
interrupt you for one moment
i've let you go on and i appreciate your
testimony but can you relate it to the
bill to set up a commission i'm trying
to
put the two together i got one more
paragraph and then i'll relate it
so the atvs are not only doing damage
wherever they are but they contain the
implicit threat that those who directly
attempt to defend themselves or the
terrain from being damaged will be
punished
legislation permitting atvs is
legislation that permits damages to
others and permits the punishment of
those who resist this damage
situations unacceptable and this
committee needs to abandon its
assumption that humans are central in
this world and have any rights to damage
any others for their own pleasure
and the connection with the committee is
that there's a presumption that atvs
have a right
to be out there in the first place and i
don't see anybody questioning
their right to be out there
that's the connection does that make
sense
yes thank you for your testimony
is that
anyone have any questions of the witness
if she'll take questions
i don't see any questions thank you very
much
is there anyone else that wants to speak
on house bill 1188
i'll ask one more time anybody else to
speak on house bill
1188 if not i'll ask do we have anybody
on the blue sheets
and they are
all pros um
jace weston
chris pistoria and abby evano
i believe that was joyce you said joyce
joyce joyce
okay thank you very much i now will
declare the hearing on hb 1188 close
thank you
that was our last bill for this
afternoon
i believe we'll meet again next
wednesday i think the schedule's already
gone out
uh representative post
uh
next week
you